we'll take a look at some more
developments in the ukraine conflict
activists supporting ukraine have seized
a london mansion belonging to russian
oligarch oleg deripaska it comes days
after the billionaire oil tycoon was
targeted by uk sanctions protesters want
the building to house refugees from
ukraine police are at the scene
oliver bulow joins us now he's author of
the new book butler to the world how
britain became the servant of tycoons
tax dodgers kleptocrats and criminals
oliver thanks so much for joining us so
london uh is a haven for russian
oligarchs why is the city in particular
so popular among oligarchs
yeah i should say for starters that it's
not just a haven for russian oligarchs
it's a haven for any oligarchs uh you
name them we have them uh essentially uh
britain i mean obviously anyone who's
been to london knows that it has lots
going for it if you're wealthy there's
lots to buy we have top end shops we
have schools great universities all of
these things but we have a second
advantage that doesn't really get
discussed so much which is that though
your wealth is very secure here it's
protected by the british british legal
system by the british police
it's not going to be investigated by the
british legal system either so it isn't
just a great place to spend money it's
also a really great place to keep money
and you can keep it here forever
now those oligarchs are becoming the
target of western sanctions are those
sanctions working
um
i suppose it depends what it means to
say are they working um you know i'm not
quite sure
that everyone is in agreement about what
the target the aim of the sanctions
is some people say
that the hope is that by sanctioning
oligarchs and costing them money they
will then come to put pressure on putin
the man who has made them so much money
because they've got rich or got richer
during his time in office other people
say that the oligarchs are essentially
extensions of the russian state so
freeze by freezing their money you're
more or less just freezing russian state
money i think both of those arguments
suggest that what we're trying to do is
trying to find policy leavers that allow
us to put pressure if not on putin
himself then on the people around him by
depriving them of all the toys the bling
the luxury goods the football clubs and
you know i think it's too early to say
if they'll work but
i think it's probably worth a shot it's
pretty better than most of the other
alternative options we've got
let's talk about putin himself we know
his personal wealth is very well hidden
how can sanctions effect effectively
target him if at
all putin
i'm not sure it even makes sense to talk
about putin being wealthy i think if
russia is your current account you don't
really need a deposit account i don't
think if he has offshore wealth anywhere
then you know it's probably not very
much in comparison to the other
oligarchs the other oligarchs have huge
offshore wealth you know perhaps half of
all the wealth owned by russians is
owned offshore by oligarchs if these
oligarchs you know want to get back to
those cushy lifestyles what do they need
to do what needs to happen or has the
world's relationship with russian
oligarchs really changed forever
i'd be surprised if our relationship
with russian oligarchs had changed
forever
western countries britain in particular
but not only britain have been
historically very welcome to work to
bring in anyone with money however
we need to recognize that that as long
as this crisis lasts there will be
sanctions on russia and it will be much
harder for oligarchs to come here and
spend their money so i suppose the
answer is what western politicians want
the answer to be which is if you want to
come back and enjoy your bling in our
capital cities you're going to have to
tell putin to stop killing ukrainians um
and that
is the challenge how many of these
oligarchs have that kind of influence
anymore how many of them could just walk
into putin and ask him for a favor like
stop invading ukraine i don't think any
of them do so i think we're going to
have to get used to a world for a while
at least while this crisis lasts when
the russian oligarchs are no longer
going to be splashing the cash in the
bars and villas of south of france or in
the you know the mansions of london or
in the islands of greece or the
caribbean
oliver bulow thank you so much for
joining us
it's my pleasure thank you for having me